[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike czelski is the
philadelphia choir columnist he's
covered the uh 76ers for nearly 20 years
and uh mike joins us on the program all
right mike what do you think the mood is
with uh sixer fans
i think the uh philadelphia police need
to guard all the bridges in and around
the city
um because there's gonna be some people
heading there
and um ready to take the deep plunge not
to be too dark about it
where do you think the anger lies a lot
of it at ben simmons
a lot of it ben simmons um because ben
violated kind of the first rule of
philadelphia sports
which is you can go down but you better
go down trying
and the fact that he kind of withered
away at the end there
didn't want clearly didn't want the ball
in his hands you know that passed up
dunk
is going to be the subject of
documentary filmmaking for years to come
i think
and then you had doc when he was
questioned after the game can you win a
championship with him
and he he answered it honestly i was
surprised he did
saying i don't know that where prior to
this
it felt like doc was always there to
remind the media
ben simmons is a special player can you
can they win a championship with ben
simmons
they can win a championship with ben
simmons i think i don't think they can
win a championship with ben simmons as
their point guard uh you can't have a
point guard
abdicating his role in the offense uh
completely to the degree that that
simmons does
i mean he just stands there under the
basket and becomes
a non-factor a non-option you can't even
throw him the ball
because he doesn't want to go to the
foul line um it's a it's a really
complex bad situation in that he's
gotten worse in that regard since he's
been in the league
i mean his numbers were all down this
season there's been a lot made in
philadelphia about how
doc rivers was going to be the the new
coach who was going to come in and
you know unleash ben but if you look at
ben's numbers and you watch the quality
of his play over the course of the
season
he did not improve as a player under doc
he got worse
and then he doesn't even attempt field
goals in the fourth quarter
i mean that i mean that's so telling
here mike that he
and the mental aspect of this this isn't
something you just go into a gym and say
hey come on in and shoot some free
throws like this
there's more to this than just we're
going to fix your form which would be
really difficult to do as well
do the do the 76ers have the
infrastructure
to be able to do this and and say all
right and we're going to take time
we learn you know from previous players
that you know have
the yep shooting yips well well i mean
dan let's let's be honest about this
they as it turned
out they drafted players number one
overall in back-to-back seasons
in ben simmons and markelle fultz who
can't
shoot i mean this is and it's not you
know they try
and they can't do it they had a mental
block about it and we can
you're right we can talk all we want
about simmons form and i've written
columns about this about how his elbow
flares out and
his form is terrible and he's
ambidextrous and maybe
it would be better if he weren't it's
not about the form anymore
he does not want to go to the foul line
um
and to answer your question about
whether the sixers can sort this out
they had a dry run at this with markelle
fultz and they weren't able to do
it and now you've got it with simmons
all over again and
i think the worst part of it is is that
his teammates see it
and they know it you watch that clip of
that passed up dunk again
you see joel embiid putting his hands in
the air like what are you doing ben just
throw the ball down and
you know that kind of thing gums up an
offense it creates tension on a team
where
a team can't afford it um you know the
scuttlebutt in philadelphia is that this
is it for ben simmons there and
at this point i find it hard to disagree
yeah i'm trying to figure this out of
does this become a carson wentz-like
situation
that you almost feel like you have to
let him go for the betterment of both
the organization and the quarterback i
think it's starker than the wench
situation there was still some debate
and divide in philadelphia over whether
the eagles ought to keep wentz whether
the problems that the eagles went
through last season
were solely on wence or mostly on wentz
you know there were questions about the
offensive line all that kind of stuff
this is far more naked you can see it he
does not want to participate in the
offense
and you can see how that trickles down
look joel embiid had eight turnovers
last night and that's bad
and he didn't rise to the occasion in
the way that kevin durant did or
giannis did the other night but he's not
the kind of player who you want creating
off the dribble
you need a player a point guard who can
get a player like embiid and a player
like tobias harris into the flow of an
offense
and right now the sixers don't have that
and everybody can see it and all those
eyes are going to one place and that's
been sentenced
so what do you do in the off-season is
is there
a trade market for ben simmons that's a
great question
i mean look daryl murray tried during
the season i mean they came very close
to making that deal for james harden
um you know they they wanted harden they
were willing to move simmons to get it
the irony of all that is that simmons
came back after that
trade fell through and harden ended up
with the nets and played great for a
while
um but i think is there is there the
market that there once was
no there can't possibly be after these
seven games that he played against the
hawks
but i think maury's gonna have to try to
get creative because if they bring him
back and they try to run this back
without making some significant changes
boy it's going to be a hard go for them
next year in the city
is the process still going on mike
you know i feel like dan i was an
advocate of the process i loved what sam
hickey was doing i felt like the process
sort of kind of ended once he resigned
um there's been so much upheaval and so
many changes since then they've gone
through brian colangelo they went
through a year without really a gm
where they ended up trading away mikhail
bridges for zaire smith
um you know they they let jimmy butler
walk and and sign tobias harris instead
uh you know now we have doc and daryl
you know in here
um the process has ended um i think
we're far enough removed from what hinky
was doing and was trying to do to say
look you know they took a big swing it
didn't work
and in some ways philadelphia was kind
of the worst place for it for trying
something like this because philadelphia
sports fans
and and sports followers are most
comfortable in like a defensive crouch
right they don't want to leave
themselves open
to the possibility of failure they want
to protect themselves as much as they
can
that's why the series lost hurts so much
dan is that the six pictures were
favored
it was one thing to have the eagles beat
the patriots when nick foles
the backup is leading them to
championship glory
it's another thing when a team is
supposed to win a series
philadelphia hates that i use the
analogy
that if you could have ben simmons in a
role that's similar to draymond green
with golden state where he's the
third or fourth option where you you
know his passing
defense and rebounding if there's a way
to kind of
and it's it sounds strange to say it
that you got to kind of
hide him or put him in a position where
he can succeed this is all you ask him
to do
and i don't know if that's possible i
i'm not sure it is
either not with the money he's making i
mean can you afford under the salary cap
to have a guy who makes 30 40 million
dollars a year
you know be draymond green i mean
nothing against draymond he's a terrific
player but
you know he wasn't steph curry he wasn't
kevin durant he wasn't klay thompson
so you know what do you do if you're the
sixers as you said
you can't really hide a guy who's making
that much money
uh it just gives you more to write mike
they they just
they write these columns for you hey
i'll take it man i'll take it every time
thank you mike we appreciate your time
thanks for having me dan appreciate it
mike
cielski who writes for the philadelphia
inquirer